listen talk about someone who is missed
yeah and loved yes Al Roker explains his
absence from The Today Show Mr Roker you
got a check of our weather yeah we sure
do severe weather opening up about a new
health battle that required a hospital
stay we were the first ones with that
outdoor studio and going out and being
with people and that's what we do but
Roker's been missing from the New York
City Plaza and a lot of you have been uh
wondering about our buddy Al wilker and
on Friday the iconic weatherman reveals
he's in the hospital following a blood
clot in his leg which led to more clots
in his lungs well this morning we can
tell you that he is doing well as Roker
put it on Instagram quote after some
medical whack-a-mole I am so fortunate
to be getting terrific Medical Care and
on the way to recovery thanks for all
the well wishes and prayers and hope to
see you soon and you know a couple of
days you guys are probably like and all
of us were like okay
we'll see you soon buddy rokers today
family also showing love in the comments
Hoda Kotb says hurry back to us counting
the days while Jenna Bush Hager reminds
Roker you are missed and loved beyond
measure Savannah Guthrie writes you're
the strongest person we know it's a good
news bad news kind of thing but this
isn't the first time rokers had to put
his health before work yeah you know I
feel good you know I had to deal with
prostate cancer and in 2020 he was
diagnosed with prostate cancer good news
is we caught it early uh not great news
is that it's a little aggressive so I'm
going to be taking some time off to take
care of this but thankfully Roker told
E.T in April he's doing great so far so
good but even a cancer diagnosis didn't
stop him from reporting on Hurricane Ida
the following year
ah
all right sorry I guess we lost
communication
certifications Chuck uh right now we are
looking at imminent landfall of this
storm some fans were left scratching
their heads wondering why Roker would
take such a challenging assignment amid
his diagnosis but the legendary
meteorologist wouldn't have it any other
way why is NBC putting him out there I
volunteered to come out here this is
what I do if we're not going to do
something that's going to put ourselves
at Harm's Way fast forward to 2022
Roker's already planning his next
on-screen gig as he continues his
recovery from the hospital we've got
thousands of Marchers raring to go yeah
the TV personality is still scheduled to
co-host the Macy's Thanksgiving Day
Parade next week at the end of the day
what's important is you go home to the
people you love and you work with the
people that you respect and and that's
all that matters
[Music]